today on campaign check the Institute
for Fiscal Studies delivers its verdict
on the political parties manifestos
labour and the Conservatives have
presented very different tax and
spending plans but the IFS says neither
of these men is leveling with the
electorate the Conservatives say they'll
increased day-to-day spending on public
services by a relatively modest three
billion pounds that's allowed them to
promise they will not increase income
tax national insurance or v80 but there
are FSA unco stood measures including
Social Care and capital spending on
things like northern powerhouse rail I
mean they will have to spend more
leaving them with a choice of busting
their budget or raising taxes the
Conservatives dispute this analysis but
the IFS say they continue to pretend tax
rises will never be needed Labor's
problem is quite at the other end of the
scale the IFS say jeremy corbyn's plan
for 73 billion pounds of extra day to
day public spending to pay for it labor
servile increased taxes for the highest
paid 5 percent those earning more than
80,000 pounds a year and on businesses
but labour also have on costed measures
notably the commitment to reimburse
women who lost out on state pensions
that's estimated at 58 billion pounds
Labour's say they please their manifesto
is seen as too ambitious but the IFS say
their tax plans don't just affect the
richest 5% the abolition for example of
marriage allowance will apply to many
people who earn less than 80 thousand
pounds a year so to say the only the
richest will pay more is clearly not
true what does all of this mean for the
national debt the IFS say that under
Labour's plans it would rise to more
than three-quarters of national income
the Liberal Democrats plans judge the
most fiscally responsible actually see
debt falling and under the Conservatives
assuming an orderly brexit debt would
also be relatively stable but here's the
kicker should the Conservatives win and
trade talks end in a No Deal brexit at
the end of next year debt would increase
to over 80% of GDP the IFS has tried to
plot a course through the high economics
and low electioneering of the party
manifestos and their conclusion is one
that my
chime with voters natural prejudices
neither of the main parties is being
honest